the Disney verse is made out of dozens
of magical kingdoms
however where they end and where they
begin is quite the mystery watch until
the end to find out how every Disney
Kingdom is connected and how the world
of descendants comes into play are the
United States of auradon the center of
the world let's go and find out Disney
fans are well aware that their favorite
movies take place in an alternate
universe the Disney verse is made out of
numerous kingdoms and many of them are
connected with each other
we know that Queen Elsa and Princess
Anna rule over arendelle while their
cousin Rapunzel is the princess of
Corona although these are made-up places
some Disney Princesses hail from actual
countries like China and North America
Mulan and Pocahontas live in these areas
respectively but their stories take
place on very different timelines the
same can be said about tiana who was
born in New Orleans where as Cinderella
Belle and the Beast were brought up in
France aladdin and Jasmine on the other
hand come from the kingdom of Agrabah
which exudes middle-eastern vibes
snow-white also hails from a magical and
nonsensical land which is referred to as
the fourth kingdom as you can see each
and every Disney movie occurs in its own
individual time in place yet somehow
these very different areas were combined
into one large country descendants fans
know that all of these magical worlds
were combined into one but how did the
United States of auradon come to be and
why did everyone agreed to be lumped
into one single continent United States
of auradon the first dissonant film was
released in 2015 and it's here that we
found out that our don was the place to
be
despite its big and enchanting
reputation the United States of auradon
is barely 24 years old our don was said
to be the promised land still many
inhabitants aren't exactly having a
jolly good time this is made obvious by
the fact that the Isle of the Lost is a
very real and agonizing place for
centuries heroes have suffered at the
hands of villains which is why our don
has such a great appeal the United
States of auradon is made out of every
single Disney Kingdom however they all
appears to be combined and to living as
one 18 magical kingdoms were united to
create the brand-new continent and it's
here that our heroes live in complete
harmony but even the most appealing
places have dark faces which is why
after 20 years of peace
villains began planning an uprising
we'll walk you through a
play-by-play of every single Kingdom and
where they're located at the end of this
video we've also got some maps to show
you but before we do that let's find out
which magical being is responsible for
uniting these 18 glorious fairytale
kingdoms fairy godmother you guessed it
our heroes Oh their home and safety to
the one and only fairy godmother after
all you can't have a fairy tale Kingdom
without a fairy right many of us
remember fairy godmother from the
classic Disney film Cinderella it was
here that she helped Cinderella
transform into a beautiful and
well-dressed maiden before sending her
off to the ball fairy godmother can
sense when people are hurting which is
both a gift and a curse without this
magical fairy the United States of
auradon simply wouldn't exist fairy
godmothers magic wand can do anything
from turning a pumpkin into a class a
carriage to uniting eighteen kingdoms on
one single timeline there isn't anything
she can't do well maybe there's one
thing fairy godmother can't rid her
rivals hearts of evil so instead of
rehabilitating them she trapped them on
the Isle of the lost despite all of this
fairy godmother is a very kind person
who wants to see the good side prevail
sure she might not be too fond of
villains but she doesn't mind that her
daughter Jane is dating the son of
Cruella De Vil in the end fairy
godmother can sense when someone's
intentions are pure still many of us
wonder why she hasn't spent her free
time fighting for v/k rights but that
isn't the only strange thing about fairy
godmother no magic it's no secret that
magic is found down upon in auradon
in fact heroes were encouraged to hand
over their magical artifacts to the
museum of cultural history fairy
godmother knows better than anyone that
magic can help those in need while being
a whole lot of fun but for some reason
she stood by Belle on the Beast
when they declared that magic should be
abandoned magic isn't allowed on the
Isle of the Lost
for obvious reasons but why wouldn't it
be part of our dime fairy godmother
willingly gave up her wand and began
living like a normal human being as the
headmistress of auradon prep she
instructs her students on how to be good
without using outside forces but as many
of us have noticed there's just no
escaping magic it's everywhere we look
be it never land or the enchanted lake
it's clear that Belle and the Beast are
trying to run a very
and peaceful community but not everyone
is meant for the mundane in fact fairies
like flora fauna and Merryweather were
very upset by the no magic rule after
all they'd never performs tedious tasks
without magic before so why should they
start now our dawn isn't like any place
we've ever seen in fact he defies more
laws than a follows like for instance
how did fairy godmother manage to bring
people back from the dead and what price
did she have to pay for her actions
alternate reality it's common knowledge
that mortals should never interfere with
the cycle of life just because you know
the spell doesn't mean you have the
right to use it no one knows this better
than fairy godmother still she meddled
with the afterlife when she brought the
villains back from the dead to imprison
them on the Isle of the Lost
this excruciating fate roused them from
their peaceful slumbers and led them to
be imprisoned on a magic --less Island
now if that isn't every villains version
of Hell we don't know what is the United
States of Aragon belongs to a different
reality
in fact some might even call it an
alternate universe fairy godmother used
her magic powers to pull the kingdoms
together creating a new world with
borders still as many of you know all of
the Disney movies take place in
different eras so basically fairy
godmother had to bring everyone to the
same timeline before infusing their
lands bringing people back from the
grave is definitely black magic so we're
assuming that a price had to be paid
could this be the real reason magic is
no longer allowed in our time could
fairy godmother have maxed out her power
source by creating an alternate reality
let us know what you think in the
comments section kang feastin Queen
Belle King beasts used to be a villain
he was rude stubborn selfish and unkind
heck he even turned an old lady away
during a storm despite having dozens of
rooms to offer her thankfully his curse
isolated him thus turning him into the
man he was supposed to be with Belle by
aside beasts began to toy with the
notion of the promised land when he
marries Belle the couple chose to forego
their honeymoon to create the United
States of auradon with fairy godmothers
help of course little is explained about
the process but we can only imagine that
the Beast and fairy godmother travelled
to different realms to find out which
magical kingdom
wanted to join their nation once
everyone was in accord fairy godmother
used her magic wand to unite the world
and beast and Belle were named king and
queen of our dime princesses and princes
were allowed to keep their kingdoms and
titles but they still viewed the beasts
family as number one but why were Belle
and beast crowned sure united kingdom's
might have been their idea but they
wouldn't have been able to do so without
magic so why go on to ban it
pros and cons of the new world the
United States of auradon might seem like
the perfect place to be but this is only
because many issues have been swept
under the rug how could a king who used
to be a villain punished BK's and
imprison them for their entire lives
this just doesn't seem logical if beasts
didn't want villains to ruin his utopia
why go through the trouble of bringing
them back to life anyone born on the
Isle of the Lost doesn't get a fair
chance at life instead they're raised by
bitter villains who want nothing more
than to be wicked to the core on the
plus side are Adan is a place of
happiness when where people can roam
freely and safely it is ruled by kind
and just people who want the best for
their nation are dine could have been
the perfect place but civilians were
stripped of their powers which is
perhaps the biggest con of all imagine
knowing that you have magic running
through your veins but not being allowed
to use it there are many pros and cons
to living in auradon but the good
definitely outweighs the bad after all
who wouldn't want to live within close
quarters to every single Disney royal
I'm guessing you don't have much
experience with heat nope the map of
auradon descendants fans have been
curious about the united states of
auradon ever since it first appeared on
the map whereas the Disney verse looks a
lot like Earth auradon is its own place
entirely the United States of auradon is
separated by the Great Wall there are 11
regions beneath the Great Wall and 7
beyond it who's ready to explore the
brand's new world beneath the Great Wall
first on the list is Cinderella's burg
which is home to charming castle and
Cinderella's burg City it's here that
Chad charming grew up and learned to be
a pompous royal we all love to hate
north of Cinderella's burg lies westerly
as its name entails westerly makes up
the western portion of auradon
Robin Hood lives in Locksley which can
be found in westerly next up is East
Riding which is commonly known as King
George Town
East Riding is often compared to London
England which is where Cruella De Vil
comes from Tangletown and Aurora can be
found in the south of auradon in a
region commonly known as the South
Riding
it's here that Rapunzel and Aurora live
both princesses have their own kingdoms
in neighboring cities
whereas Coronas name was changed to
Tangletown Sleeping Beauty's Kingdom was
given the name auroria then there's
Camelot Heights which is home to King
Arthur and Merlin who live in Camelot
and Pendragon Castle respectively this
part of our don is technology free due
to Merlin and Arthur's beliefs towering
heights is west of the summer lands and
north of East Riding it borders Hook's
Bay and is known for its most popular
location Bayou de Orleans this is where
King Naveen and Queen Tiana live however
Rapunzel's tower is also located in the
region which is where the name towering
Heights stems from our Adhan central is
located in the center of the continent
and directly faces the Isle of the Lost
it is home to King Adam Queen Belle and
Ben however it also hosts cities like
our Don City Fortuna and Belle Harbor
all children attend our don prep which
is located in the capital then there is
North Way which is where Mulan li Shang
and Lonnie live this northern state is
made to resemble China where Mulan is
originally from Snow White and Prince
Florian live in charmington this state
is connected to shallows keep by a small
bridge next up we've got Olympus which
can be found on top of mountain Olympus
Olympus is directly above Bayou de
Orleans and is where all the gods live
last but not least is the Isle of the
Lost which is considered to be part of
auradon
now that we've mapped out everything
beneath the Great Wall let's check out
the other side beyond the Great Wall
believe it or not but Netherland can
actually be found in auradon however it
isn't attached to the mainland this is
where Peter Pan and the lost boys roam
but they tend to keep to themselves
then there's lone Keef which is where
aladdin and Jasmine live it's most
prominent Kingdom is still referred to
as Agrabah the furthest part of our Don
is known as the borderlands which is
where Far Away kingdoms exist we also
know that winters keep Schwarzwald
and a fellow Theo are located beyond the
great wall however little information is
given about
who lives there still we can't help or
think that Anna and Elsa live in winters
keep while Moana lives in a fellow Thea
so there you have it how every Disney
Kingdom is connected in descendants
which Kingdom is your favorites let us
know in the comments section and while
you're at it tell us what you think
about our Adhan should heroes be allowed
to use magic is our dawn really as grey
as they say it is you be the judge we
hope you enjoyed our magical video for
more Disney related content go ahead and
hit that subscribe button
before you go give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to leave a
comment thanks for watching the things
we'll see you next time
[Music]